what's your favorite part about the U.S
championships being held here in St
Louis I always loved playing in St Louis
I always love the hospitality that Rex
and Genie provide for the players and I
always like to come back and to see my
friends at this tournament specifically
um it's always really well organized and
runs really smoothly and the players are
always really nice and fun to hang out
with
I think this time in Saint Louis is very
beautiful I I love
walking around and full times one of my
favorite Seasons we have a lot of trees
around so I love being in Saint Louis in
October I like how we get treated in San
Luis it feels like home and we get a lot
of respect from the club and all the
employees so it's just a nice feeling to
play in a place where chess is
appreciated it's always amazing to have
the tournament here in St Louis
especially since I live here anyways and
I go to St Louis University I'm very
excited to play the U.S Championship
again it's always a very tough
competition and you do get to see a lot
of players that maybe you haven't seen
in a long time and especially with
school I feel like a lot of players
especially the younger ones tend to be
very busy so it's just a very good test
for yourself and to see how you're doing
chest wise I really like the atmosphere
here and like like the entire city just
feels like super friendly well it's like
a really special thing for me to kind of
come back here because I haven't played
um like an in-person U.S Championship
since 2019
um so it's been a few years it's also
the year that I won so it's like kind of
a really strange experience to be back
because it feels like it's been such a
long time
um but I just really love like you know
the chance to play against the top
people in the country and like it's
always such a great experience playing
St Louis in general you know with
commentary and like the play menu it
feels great this is my 14th year I
haven't skipped anyone ever since the
tournament's been taking place in San
Luis it's exciting I did not expect to
be invited once again because I've had
these terrible years of playing and I've
focused a lot of com on commentary and
things but it's great to be back I'm
very excited to play it back over the
board and hopefully it will be a good
tournament I always joke and so maybe if
it's not Saint Louis I already would
stop playing chess it gives me
motivation it's gift like it's wonderful
how organizers treat people and for me
it's also important I like playing chess
like together with the strongest or
players and I like to compete and this
is very difficult to determine just one
small part be it in Saint Louis this is
like second home definitely for me and
I've been here many times
I enjoy being here all the time and this
is just like favorite favorite place to
play chess there's so much chess here I
like I've been here before it's not my
first time here but every time I'm in St
Louis I'm bombarded with chess
everywhere there's like there's a huge
chest piece and like a giant a
chessboard with like giant chess pieces
outside of the World Chess Hall of Fame
there's chess boards like in the hotel
that I'm staying at even like the the
really nice wooden ones there's like
flyers everywhere too and just the
promotion of Chess everywhere I see and
it feels so good to be bombarded with
chess it feels like inspiration for the
actual chest that I'll be playing in
this tournament and it just it really
gets me pumped up honestly I mean I like
the playing chess part of the US
championships for sure I mean like the
competition I enjoy the camaraderie as
well all and like all of our evening
dinners with Rex and just seeing like
all the St Louis people again the
commentators and my friends here
well I really like obviously all the
events hosted by the St Louis jazz club
uh one thing that I'm really excited
about is to be playing against all these
strong players like many of these
players have been my Idols for many
years and they still are so it's really
cool to be getting to playing against
them if you are like really nice and and
yeah like in general the playing Hall
um you know the places like the food
around here it's always good experience
I think U.S championship in St Louis is
my absolute favorite event I always love
coming back here just the chess club and
people who work around the tournament
everything is just so wonderful